das ist wirklich eine
erfolgversprechende nachricht ein
forschungsteam aus zürich hat eine neue
klasse an antibiotika aufgespürt die
effektiv gegen lebensbedrohliche
bakterien wirken die neu entdeckten
antibiotika zeichnen sich durch einen
einzigartigen wirkungsmechanismus aus
und könnten damit sogar gegen resistente
krankenhauskeime ankommen können wir uns
also doch noch vor der drohnen keim
apokalypse retten klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivität locken nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's ich will
kommen das besondere an dieser neu
entdeckten antibiotika klasse ist ihr
einzigartiger wirkmechanismus denn
dieser verhindert dass die erreger eine
außenmembran aufbauen können und töten
die teils lebensbedrohlichen bakterien
somit effektiv ab ein züricher
forschungsteam hat diese meldung jetzt
in der renommierten fachzeitschrift
nature veröffentlicht eine
erfolgversprechende nachricht denn
resistente bakterien sind eine
gefährliche bedrohung für die gesamte
menschheit über dieses problem vor dem
die weltgesundheitsorganisation vero
eindringlich warnt berichten wir immer
wieder ihr kriegs- und science fiction
das große problem die
antibiotikaresistenzen verbreiten sich
weltweit im worst case sind ärzteteams
selbst bei kleinen wundinfektionen aber
natürlich auch bei blutvergiftung oder
lungenentzündungen die hände gebunden
nicht nur einmal wurde ein antibiotikum
nach dem anderen verabreicht doch
vergebens diese übermächtigen bazillen
sind wirklich eine riesige gefahr für
uns alle da sind sich mikrobiologin und
mikrobiologen einig es gibt schätzungen
nach dem schon bald mehr menschen durch
solche erreger sterben werden als durch
krebserkrankungen hinzu kommt für die
pharmaunternehmen weltweit rechnet es
sich finanziell schon lange nicht mehr
neue antibiotika zu entwickeln und so
wurde die letzte neue klasse von
antibiotika die gegen sogenannte
gramnegative bakterien ankommen in den
60er jahren auf dem markt gebracht
selbst gegen das letzte mittel der wahl
das reserveantibiotika mit der
bezeichnung call ist ihn nehmen die
resistenzen weltweit zu ein
horrorszenario dass uns dadurch also
drohen könnte falls forschungsteams
nicht bald antibiotika mit euren
neuartigen wirkmechanismen gegen
gramnegative bakterien entwickeln da
kommt die
erfolgsmeldung aus zürich also ganz
recht nach angaben des forschungsteams
wirken die neuartigen antibiotika gegen
diverse gefährliche bakterien konkret
handelt es sich um eine neue familie von
synthetischen antibiotika die gegen
gramnegative mikroben ankommen vor allem
ihr wirkungsmechanismus ist bislang
einzigartig dazu john robinson der an
der studie beteiligt war
die neuen antibiotika interagieren mit
proteinen der außenmembran von
gramnegativen bakterien nach unseren
ergebnissen binden die antibiotika
einerseits an fett ähnliche membran
komponenten den sogenannten
lipopolysaccharide und andererseits
anders membranproteinen ba ma das für
den aufbau der äußeren hülle von
gramnegativen bakterien essentiell ist
vereinfacht formuliert heißt das also
dass die gefährlichen erreger daran
gehindert werden ihre äußere membran
aufzubauen die neu aufgespürten
antibiotika binden also an das protein
mit der bezeichnung obama das aber
unerlässlich für den aufbau der
außenmembran ist diese ist für die
gefährlichen bakterien also
lebensnotwendig denn sie ist nicht nur
ein wichtiger schutz beispielsweise von
toxischen umweltfaktoren sondern auch
vor antibiotika zu dem verhilft die
außenmembran den mikroben dabei
nährstoffe und signalmoleküle
aufzunehmen oder abzugeben
durch die bindung der neuartigen
antibiotika an das membranproteinen ba
ma wird die außenmembran also zerstört
und die zellen platzen so einleuchtend
und logisch dieser wirkmechanismus
klingt hierbei handelt es sich um eine
premiere im medizinbereich dazu john
robinson trotz ihrer bedeutung zielen
keine der bisher klinisch eingesetzten
antibiotika auf schlüssel proteine die
für die bio genese der außenmembran
erforderlich sind klar ist aber auch
dass die neu entdeckten substanzen noch
lange nicht marktreif sind ein erstes
leid molekül der neuartigen antibiotika
klasse befindet sich erst in der
präklinischen phase doch die
verantwortlichen forschenden sind
äußerst motiviert die substanzen auch in
die klinische prüfung am menschen zu
bringen und das möglichst bald viele
haben übrigens in diesen tagen mit
schnupfen zu tun schnupfen was tun
anklicken anschauen und dem megacoolen
kanal der medizinstudent unbedingt
abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran